Let's take a look at NCBI's newly enhanced
Genome Data Viewer.
You can now view AND analyze more than 500
eukaryotic Reference Sequence, or RefSeq,
genomes.
Take the next 2 minutse to discover the GDV's
versatility.
On the viewer's home page you may find your
organism of interest, or use a common or scientific
name to quickly search for an organism or
explore what other organisms are available.
You can begin your analysis of a particular
assembly by entering a gene, a location, a
phenotype, or even an NCBI accession number.
Once in the viewer, you have all of the features
of the Sequence viewer, including, numerous
zoom controls, and extensive Track configuration,
where you can load pre-defined sets of tracks,
either NCBI Recommended Track Sets for specific
topics, or save and manage your own sets of
tracks within your My NCBI account.
There is also a Configuration menu for choosing
among hundreds of tracks that we provide,
including expression tracks of RNA-seq data
and many new variation tracks.
And don't forget that you can upload your
own data either here, or
use the Your data widget on the left
to add a track of aligned data from a file
on your local machine or at a URL.
Your new track appears in the Sequence Viewer,
allowing you to compare it with the wealth
of NCBI tracks.
We also recently added a BLAST function, allowing
you to see recent BLAST alignments in the
viewer.
That was just a sampling of the Genome Data
Viewer's capabilities.
Look for links to the GDV on many NCBI record
pages, including Assembly, Genome, GEO, Gene,
and coming soon to BLAST.